okay guys it's been a little while since
I've done one of these vlogs so I
thought I would update you on a few
things that are going on in my life but
before I do that there's a few things I
want to talk about few projects that I'm
not involved in but I want you to know
about first off the ever wonderful Jamie
Mills otherwise known as Jamie has it
loaded a fantastic how to study video if
you're here because of my how to study
effectively video be sure to go and
check his out cuz I'm sure he's gonna
benefit you as well
link in the description also if you'd
like to get involved in a competition
with the Ox tweet project if you don't
know what that is that's where people in
Oxford
use the hashtag ox tweet to talk about
their daily lives you can search for a
hashtag and it just gives you a snapshot
of life at the University it's a
brilliant idea and Jamie's trying to
promote it in schools across the country
and in order to do that he's sending out
postcards and he needs a design to go on
the front off those postcards and he's
looking for people to submit designs if
you'd like to get involved that
competition then there's also a link in
the description and lastly in terms of
projects if you're thinking of applying
to Durham University there is now the
Duvall project where a guy called Oscar
is vlogging about his life at the
university's archaeology and
anthropology student is the first year
if you're interested in applying to
Durham be sure to check his videos out I
really liked his first vlog so really
excited to hear more from him so what's
happening with me
I was the PhD I at the moment I'm
working towards a literature review so a
literature review is where you read all
the papers that you can are there
relevant to your particular subject so
for me that's stratosphere troposphere
coupling and you organize all that
information into a document which is
going to be about 20 pages long and you
submit that to the University the actual
goal of it isn't so much the submission
it's the process of collating the
information so I've been reading papers
left right and centre I don't even know
how many papers I've read now
fortunately stratospheric troposphere
coupling is actually a very new subject
the idea that the stratosphere influence
the troposphere the middle and lower
sections of the atmosphere has anybody
been around since the nineties really so
there aren't as many papers to go
through as there in other subjects but
all the same it's a lot of work apart
from that I've been doing a lot of
programming the attributes science which
I'm looking at the moment is looking at
pressure anomalies at set heights in the
atmosphere and in order to look at that
I have
to take in atmospheric data now to
convert it because people measure
variables now atmosphere like wind and
temperature and stuff like that that's
set pressure there are reasons for doing
that which aren't going to now but I
have to convert that to measuring those
variables at constant height which is a
relatively simple process but because
you're dealing with a large data set you
have to make sure that you're doing it
very efficiently otherwise your program
will take years to run literally I
worked out my initial program would have
taken five years to convert all the data
in addition to that stuff I'm also
taking some short courses so people who
watch my vlogs last time will know that
I took a short course in a string theory
there is a video and that come quite
seem honest I'll talk about that in a
little bit and this time I'm doing two
courses I'm doing a 20 hour course on
partial differential equations and doing
a 20 hour course on hydrodynamic
stability theory lastly to do his work
I'd like to draw your attention to a
website called Earth Nell Schoolnet this
is a website which visualizes climate
data in real time so you can look at the
wind field so the temperature feels the
pressure fields at the surface you can
look at them going up through the
atmosphere and now also ocean currents
so if you're curious about sort of ie
what the weather's doing or B how the
climate generally works go and check it
out it you can spend hours playing
around with it apart from work though as
it was last term most of what I'm doing
is singing people who watch my last term
will know that I did some a cappella C
so I'm in the madrigals group which is
early music like this
and I'm also in the Harmonix group which
is more general classical music so for
example this
and now most recently I have joined
Chapel Choir which is something that I
completely didn't expect to happen I
didn't sing at all when I was in Oxford
even though I kind of really like the
idea I just assumed I wasn't good enough
I certainly see no wasn't good enough
for the college choir so to now be
offered a place and offered offered a
scholarship in the in the chapel choir
here is absolutely unbelievable
I'm very sorry by the way if a lot of
this is old news to you if you follow me
on Twitter which is at Simon Oxford's
which you should definitely do
I hope the stuff which I'm talking about
is completely old news so sorry that I'm
boring you but so you know stick around
please of course something else which I
did in my spare time which I uploaded
quite recently was my string theory
video now you might not have seen this
but I'm really quite proud of this video
so if you missed it do you go and watch
it I want you to leave in the comments
of this video also what you liked or
didn't like about it because like I said
I want to do another video on string
theory so I want to make sure that I do
it right that string theory of video is
probably going to be 2 or 3 weeks
because I really want to do it properly
and the animation takes bloody forever
also the video got retweeted by Nicola
if you don't know who he is I'm gonna
link to his channel in the description
he's like the yoader of youtube if
you're watching this Nicola thank you so
much your praise really meant a great
deal so you're awesome
I love your videos I also recently met
with two subscribers to give an
interview about ups bridge admissions
that was by Joni and Amelia
thank you guys if you're watching it was
great to meet you both I really enjoyed
it actually
it was it was quite nice to not just
talk to a camera and talk to people who
talk back so I'm really nice to meet you
guys something I was interesting which
happened to me was I went back to Oxford
with my girlfriend to go and see a
concert in the Sheldonian theatre and
obviously was showing her around the
city and everything like she had been
and it was the first experience I had of
really going back to college and not
being there anymore and it's weird
because they made me realize how much I
missed the college even though I didn't
I didn't really think about it in those
terms at the time I really missed the
atmosphere I missed the the the the
common room and I missed all my friends
but it was really quite weird going back
and seeing locks on doors that I can go
through it makes you realize that you
don't appreciate stuff truly until it's
gone so with that in mind a massive
congratulations to everybody who's got
an offer and so hasn't been to Oxford
yet but knows they are going to also a
big shout out that the guy who in some
Peters bar stopped me to say thank you
for making my videos I didn't catch your
name so if you're watching this that
really meant a huge deal to me like
that's never happened to me before
people have just outright stopped me and
said thank you actually speaking of
Oxford I'm going to be going back in a
few weeks time for a talk the physics
society is doing an evening of student
talks and have invited me to give the
one which closes everything off so if
you're in Oxford keep an eye out for
that on the physics Society Facebook and
I might see there that's pretty much
everything it's been a little while like
I say since I've done release there's a
lot to talk about but I think that's
that's all the important stuff I II was
thinking that I might close out this
video with a little clip from Chapel
Choir because we sang a piece called
North dimittis by Gustav Holst and it
might be the most beautiful piece I've
ever sung and I'm I think the choir
really did it justice I'm really quite
tempted to upload it in full in its own
separate video on this channel so give
it a listen and if you like what you
hear you want to hear more then let me
know and I will see you quite soon
thanks for watching